mr barnes why does sam aggravate you
15 seconds to drop so what's our plan
great super bowl 55 gave us our best
look yet at marvel's new disney plus
series falcon and the winter soldier
was it a touchdown or was it a loose
ball
uh tight end i don't know football but i
do know nerd stuff
this is dt canada's nerd alert
if you're an mcu fan that's been craving
some big screen style action and fight
scenes
last night's trailer did not disappoint
and though i am one of the people that
is appreciating the slow burn tension of
our current obsession wand division
sometimes you just want to see some
explosions
buck i have a plan oh yeah what is
it now when we last left sam and bucky
old man steve rogers had entrusted
falcon with his one and only
captain america's mighty shield it's a
big honor and responsibility and opened
the door for sam to eventually take on
the role of captain america like he did
in the comics
though anthony mackie the actor that
portrays sam wilson has mentioned in the
past how he was open to the idea of his
character becoming the new cap
he's also stated that sam never actually
said he wanted that for himself and that
the series would explore
who the shield gets passed down to there
are a few candidates here
like sam bucky barnes aka the winter
soldier has also become captain america
in the comics
the fact that could put an interesting
wrinkle in the already strained
relationship
between the two avengers the other is
the mysterious figure we see in what
looks very much like captain america's
uniform in the trailer
set photos from a while back as well as
recently revealed art tell us that this
is not the og cap
but rather a new character called us
agent talking too much about his comic
book history of beers
into potential spoiler territory so i
won't get into it here
just yet here we go again huh
the trailer also gives us a look at a
couple of returning fan favorites
emily van kemp's sharing carter returns
to kick some serious butt
and the man who had the avengers nearly
destroyed themselves baron zemo
is back he and bucky have some serious
history and may very well be the show's
big bad though
in the mcu there's always a swerve so
we'll have to wait and see on that one
what did y'all think of the trailer i'm
loving the action i'm happy to see that
the love hate dynamic between sam and
bucky is carrying through
to falcon and the winter soldier what
else did you notice
is that futuristic city magic poor
what's up with the anarchist group flag
smasher
and who wants to have a staring contest
get into it in the comments below and
stay tuned for falcon in the winter
soldier coverage on et canada's nerd
alert
as the show premieres on march 19.
staring contest three two one go
just blank sweet jesus i mean how old
are you